my perception is that we see that
the standard by which tiktok is measured is
even higher than that of other large
platforms, so you can find it
as you want, we see that for the first time it
actually spurs us
on to become better in all areas and also on topics
such as transparency  Security on the
platform for users and thus also for
brands
data privacy that we
really play a leading role
there I have no idea whether those
watching here on YouTube are even hanging out
at tiktok but
we’ve definitely
heard everything from tiktokom  probably the largest
the most dynamic digital platform of the
current time and the colleague who is
coming now is the boss of it in Germany
in Austria in Switzerland in Holland
in Israel was at Google for years
and now explains tiktok let's go,
welcome to the OMR podcast is
a topic  that I've really been obsessing over
the last few months more and more  Although the
guest is the head of Germany or, to be
honest, now
certainly for Israel and Holland and
Austria and Switzerland, a
whole bouquet of countries Thomas Watzek
from Thomas moin philipp tiktok is
correct you are not in tik tok with
bite dance that is correct me  I've been at
tiktok for a long time since two and a half
years April 2020 okay and where what before
at Google and there longer 12 years oha
so there went through all the stations or
tell me a bit what was
your job yes I actually started there
from scratch  started in Dublin in 2007
that was my second station in my
career as a manager
and yes I worked my way up then
learned the basics of digital
marketing search engine marketing
display YouTube and so on
then after about two years in Dublin I also started
to lead teams in
different verticals  retail
finance then went to Hamburg
a few years ago and was d  For two
years I took care of large
insurance companies
then another team took over that I took care of
large digital
purplayers only the CHECK24 idealos in
this world did that for about five
years and then last year I moved
to Google again and
again to Berlin  and took
the team with me and last
year I actually took care of
Eastern Europe at Google yes and
then tiktok knocked and asked
if I didn't want to set it up how
does tiktok knock so there are
HR consultants or tiktor always calls
you all at once  or how
does the first one write
something like that on LinkedIn yes and then I had
but if
from the company side
a boss from the USA or from China or
or who is a boss so to speak back
then it was still Blake gently the
global business  responsible for tiktok, so to speak
, he is based in New York and it
was actually europafef
S  tuart Flint, who is now my director
boss, you can do it a little later
, he basically started at the same time as
me
at the beginning of April 2020, but at the time it
was Blake from New York, who is now
globally responsible for the business
, doesn’t mean business  CEO but he is, so to speak,
for marketing and stuff like that right
exactly at tiktok exactly he's based
in Singapore
exactly exactly so that's what I just wanted to
say show already she or something like that is the
faith or shoe she's called show or something like that I
have to say I know
the surname  I can't
pronounce it perfectly either, so I'll say
look,
okay, and just a quick
introduction, so before you go to Google,
did you do something
? I did
personal consulting for two years
, project stepping, so to speak
But then my
affinity for technology and everything
digital and the desire really got me
more  Also having the product and
doing more advice then brought it to
Google, where a good friend of mine was
already working and that’s exactly why you
spoke to Rene Ruland recently, actually
at the same university that
no longer existed in Bruchsal  okay
he was a year above me but
we known each other from university
oh blatant
yes exactly so okay spoken by my poster a
few weeks ago exactly exactly was
a nice conversation
why do you think or why can you
listen why tiktok chose you now
so  mine is already
somehow, tell me, the big
digital brand is just aspiring, um,
how did it fit? that's a
very good question, I'm sure I'm thinking about
the range of topics that I ended up doing and I
've looked after
them at Google across different
markets  different locations, but
above all across a
wide range of verticals from
traditional ones  verticals from branding
to performance and meanwhile it is
also the case that tiktok also has a very large,
very large focus on the topic of
performance advertising and since I
also have an edge in both areas,
I think that
certainly contributed to that okay and how
big is it now  your team is now
here in the markets yes several hundred
several hundred now yes so we are
in Europe we started laterally
I went from a few hundred to several
thousand and in Germany from a
double digit number of employees is
okay to several hundred so that's
communication now  is then a bit
more abstract several hundred
so usually it changes
quite dynamically anyway that’s
the other factor that’s exactly why and
were you already on tiktok
yourself when she was
addressed to me that was in 2019
I wasn’t up yet  tiktok but now of
course and then it was actually
too
so you have to say that tiktok was still in a
very early stage, so in 2019 I
spoke to my colleagues earlier
who did the
omr festival with you and said it
had just started, so you still have it,
for example  didn't play such a
big role it was
different this year from last year
and
it has now developed rapidly
so at that point in time it was certainly
still a bit of a bet when I
started it really
started to be big in Germany too
scale then came the advertising solution
exactly and now we are where we are
today what can you say so how much
sales can you say somehow what
is there what is generally out
probably now
related to Germany not quite related to a world
level something yes  Turnover not
yet, we are still a private
company, so to speak, but you can
put 50 billion on Wikipedia,
I'll leave that uncommon
but what I can say is that we've
actually had
over a billion users for quite a while now
over 100 million in europe we're coming
we always comment on milestones,
so to speak, so bigger bigger bigger
milestones there will definitely
be an update soon so what  I
can certainly reveal that it
has continued to
grow since then, but you have to
be honest, more than these billions are
not on Twitter, but
on both Dance because that is the
mother behind it forever and she is
not at all now  so young
no I mean tiktok itself is not
that young anymore it is now a strongly
accelerated five years but
I think both have been around for more than 10
years now yes exactly and we also
have other assets in there besides them
both platforms, if you think about it,
the whole range of assets in the case of dance
and then in
essence  But it is actually relevant that tiktok
the western than western blood of
your as a product outside of China
there is also one then it’s just
duien exactly you don’t have anything to do
at all so these are
actually two apps that are completely
separate from each other
and
accordingly
takes care of it, so to speak, there is also
its own management for tiktok
outside outside just and also
its own management and accordingly also
marketing of many
okay okay that means and you are
now mainly
busy with the platform to
interest that is mine  Main focus yes
exactly
but okay that means
we are probably the 50
billion of course very well thought out
already very high it has to be something
else and both have to be there because
otherwise it would have gone up very quickly very quickly
that’s I think
that’s manageable  you don't actually
but where do you stand there so what is
since the topic is so new products
new customers what what occupies us the
most right
now right
now at tiktok
actually occupies the most that of course
continue working with customers so I
would maybe start at the beginning,
so to speak, yes, what
me personally now  Of course,
what really moved me in the first step was the whole issue of building up the team in the German-speaking area of ​​Israel. I’ve had this since the beginning of
September. It was built
up by someone
else  also
from primarily, to be honest, from the
locations of Dublin
but also from other platforms from
other marketing from the market then from
customers from the industry so very very
mixed
and what my focus was basically to
build a team that is also very
specialized  is very vertical
, which means we have our own teams for
automotive for ret we have our own
agency team yes and that alone
always presupposes that we have a
wide variety of
different skills and
what I've learned from the beginning and
I've certainly taken that with me I
think Google is also known for that,
where I was from the beginning  I have attached great importance
to the issue of
culture to establish corporate culture,
especially when you are growing so quickly, so
when you are now growing from a
more or less handful
of people to several hundred
and within two years you are doing it
all the more  It's more important that you
create a very, very good culture there,
but now
you're thinking, you said several hundred people,
very, very mostly, nevertheless, people who work
in sales, well
I'll say regionally, regionally
speaking, and that certainly
also applies to working in Germany as
a whole  Most of
them are also found in our just in
safe area  ty
very large area in sales and
then we also have user
operations marketing
teams who take care of the creator is of
course now done in the USA development
is not available locally here okay that works
in the USA or in an Asia
there, to be honest I should  fit where
exactly there are
development locations everywhere now i know for
sure that there are product development teams in the USA and California
with China
so if you or you hear
tiktok at the end or at dance the mother
is then a chinese company so
where that too  also belongs to many
large American toilets unfortunately there are
also Sequoia and small Perkins
I think and something like that so
many
global inve do you come close to
coming so these Chinese influences don’t
even affect you to
be honest, so to be honest
I actually took part in the discussions
the global leadership at tiktok
and that's where the direction comes from and that's am
american in de  r rule and
also from this I believe
basic understanding that we maintain
this local approach first of all a
regional approach and then also a local
approach and then I
think the understanding is also greater
if he still encounters reservations in the
market because with  Companies say Schuh
that's there are
always questions in the press
what's this tiktok that's driving
all our young people crazy
and and if so what data
might be extracted so you hear something
or something in the market yes of course
I do of course  these questions are
asked and
my perception is that
the standard by which tiktok is measured is
even higher than that of other large
platforms, so you can find out
how you want, we see it
as an incentive to actually
get better in all areas and  also such topics
as transparency security on the
platform for users and thus also f  For
brands,
data-prives sees that we
really play a leading role there
, yes that starts with
creating transparency for the tiktok
algorithm, we already explained in 2020
how it actually works
that then continues so that we have
a  build transparency center where we
are just
publishing the latest figures where we say exactly how
do we moderate actually so it
means something in German the report
means something awkward in German reports
on the enforcement of the
community guidelines yes that means we
have objective community
community guidelines where  we say what
's okay on the platform, what's not
okay on the platform and
according to local laws
and customs and so on
and
and there on the basis of that
we moderate technologically then through
human moderators, as I said, that
's tiktok global overall  seen the
greatest team we have un  d then again
there is the possibility for users
and it is very easy to point out
if any content is not really
correct, which means that this
external observation simply means
that we and it started so sideways
that there is an extremely
large focus on it and that helps
actually
helping us by showing it
also helps us
very well to say
we're doing everything right and we're doing
it according to the local standards, rules of the
game and so on
are so big now or or
like the last one explain that his face
so I don't want to go too much into let's
say the global club the global
yes constellations and crises and and
and and and tensions I
think but of course I can
understand that and that's why
we just have to explain it better
simply because so many people use the product
n or or yes, so using events so many of
course you have a high
responsibility and you have to
live up to it, that means we have to do it
first and our responsibility
is simply
to do the right thing for our users very transparently,
yes that means if we e.g
currently well in Europe there are 100
million over 100 million in Europe
that is Germany now
there are no numbers but okay 100 million
Europe 400 million or something like that and these
are now numbers that are already
old so yes okay but the
people are  also somehow between
which age groups so the largest
target group or the majority of our
users are now 18 to 25 the strongest
growth growth we actually have 25
plus so I spoke to my
generations Janet and Müller nails more
than on other large platforms and
that is achieved by  one if one has an
algorithm that others would like to have
obviously that is particularly sticky
so who can recognize particularly well
what kind of video content is
mostly yes
the respective user user just
likes exactly so we have when you
open the app you have the this you have
the for you page which is based as
you correctly say one on  a
recommendation algorithm ultimately
and I think the exciting thing is that
behind it all there is a
content count and not socialcraft,
which means
that what matters is what content you actually like and the
fact that we are
talking about short videos, of course, means
that you have a lot  interactions
and we also create a transparent one
there are not only likes and shares
but it is also crucial how
long you watch a video how
often you watch it
maybe you also watch it repeatedly
, of course then with different strengths
signals but the system learns
very quickly what I think what but
w  what is important is and you will
surely
notice that if you use tiktok then I would go in yes
exactly but what you then notice what you
will notice is that the
content is never one-dimensional is yes that
means
we will play a variety of content very very consciously again and again
a new idea and sometimes it's something
where you say oh that's totally exciting
and sometimes what I said is always
not my thing but we
always keep it very diverse so that
you can discover new content and
so no bubble now  there arises
but it's the whole classic principle
of the
follower is actually not
that relevant anymore no I mean I still hear
about people who
have lost millions of on tiktok but
let's think well that's not the same
hard currency as that maybe  was the case with
Instagram where you say okay,
then you really had the
followers and could at least talk about it for
a while  ch specifically
achieve that is only a
small influencing factor on the side for you right now
how did you get it right so every single one
in principle every single
peace of content tells us better in German
so to speak every single
piece of content is ultimately more decisive
than than the number of followers of
course  Is it so that you can
also see what the creators are doing that you can also see what
the creators
are doing?  let's take a simple
example you have a million followers
then as a creator you may
have a video that gets 10
million views it may
be that a video only has
10,000 views because it's not well received
because it  People not interested
because people don't want to see so
you just have to
start tomorrow and ma  n makes a video about it
then I suddenly realize that can happen
very quickly yes and that is of
course also a huge opportunity for
clicks and I believe it and that also
explains these mechanics also explains
how these trends work yes
that means
it often catches on  so what you
see, so to
speak, of course, others also see to a certain extent
that means if you now, for
example, have
a topic yes it's corn that's a
funny trend right now it's gotten
very, very big is a little
boy who's being interviewed and then says he'll
be  then asked, so to speak, body you
like corn and its heart corn
and it's totally cute and it has
and what you would never foresee that it would
become such a mega trend but
people interpret that and through this
interpretation and that people have the
similar taste
then  In principle,
yes, microcommunities develop niches and sometimes
it just goes into the mainstream and that
only works w  because the
primary content graph is where people
connect via the in and less
about the they follow
what about it and more that I
then often leads to that good the
other example is booktok for
example is a mega  Trend has more
than 70 billion views of
the hashtag globally and represents tiktok
creator users
. You might not think you would have read books before you read them at first
, but it has become a mega
community, I
started out really small and then it
spilled into the mainstream  in the USA this is
now a solid
economic factor for the publishers and
ensures that books
are really sold out, so the Mio mode,
so the rap playlist via spotify
is that somehow now exactly the
literature list on tiktok okay exactly
okay another question that always comes up  what
is actually with this data so ne
so you know that now
at all so where jet  currently my data, for
example, then only registered then
tiktok where they are or who they are where they
are stored and stuff like that
I’m not there now either so tell me
carefully maybe I don’t know
so the data is currently being
stored in the USA and  in Singapore
are in the process of building a data
center in Dublin that will be
completed in 2023 that is currently under construction
and then of course European
user data will also
or then exclusively be spoken to the tablet
that often comes with it
on
young people
[music]
what like me you always read that
someone died in a tiktok challenge
or something like that that
also affects you or where you say
it actually happens to us at the moment
that there are deaths or something like
that I know now  none no
specific challenge where that happened, so to speak
, it just happened
again and again  So you have to, of course, there are
challenges or there is of
course the phenomenon that young people are
careless, so we also do a
lot of educational campaigns, so
that's of course incredibly important to us
and we've made a very simple framework, for example, which we work
with
creators who do that  then
also convey to
young people
, so to speak, if you
see something first think about it ne pause
think about it is it really what is
that could it be something dangerous and if
in doubt do something preventively to prevent something like that
basically it's like that we do it
all  We take the protection of minors extremely
seriously, so we only have the app
after the age of 13 and
we not only ensure this by
specifying our own age, but we also
delete accounts where we say
who thinks that maybe
users are under 13, yes that  were now
20 million customers in the last quarter alone
and that's one thing, we do it,
we work with awareness campaigns
and then we've built
a lot of security
measures into the product that we say if you're under
16 then your account is
automatically private, which means whatever you
do there won't happen  No, it's not general
if I'm not generally
accessible you can't
send or receive direct messages either
, and only from the age of 16 can
you actually change these changes,
so to speak, and only from then on
can you
do things like gift matching and so
on gifting  and so on that
means when buying gifts for
creators, so to speak, so we are very,
very, very, very conservative, a lot more
conservative and always a lot
more advanced than other platforms, precisely
because we naturally take on the special
responsibility, especially for young
users, very much  are aware,
politicians are sometimes surprised
since it's a bit critical,
I think that's the role of politicians, too, to
ask questions critically and
if you have a large platform you can
reach many users and it's
user-generated content, then of
course it's something that's difficult to grasp from the
outside
and to ask about
it because of the platform, you
really do everything to protect your users,
to educate them, to
moderate content that may be
dangerous, I'm legitimate and what
we have to do then is a
good job and maybe a
better job  to communicate what we are doing there
and if we do that then we will
also see that we can address these concerns very well
there is somehow a number to
implement advertising at least simulation
Financial Times
speculates that you
approach a billion in Europe last year
So that's just a new
very much larger number in advance
m asked but it was also a global and
so
okay understood what impressed you most about the platform over
the last few years that you are
looking at
that, well I mean I
experienced it myself here with my little
OMR Katz Challenge where we  People gave
money if they made awesome tiktoks out of our
podcast videos
and then amazing numbers
were created where people then shortened the
conversations with L Monte and knossi and so
on and uploaded them
that was gigantic that was the biggest
podcast heck I've ever had
i have seen and i have tried everything already on podcast
so thanks tiktok in the end
what i had most of my
do you have a good question to boil this down to
one thing
it is certainly so are certainly
the big trends that we have seen
but if we now
maybe swing over to advertisers
and
successes they've seen and
I'm actually always the most happy about it
if we really
help companies that make tiktok
big and really have this tiktok
express tax, for example,
they are the
main marketing channel for them again i think
you even wrote about it before
, meanwhile 35 million
sales that means we can do it
jobs for
you too express tax return then
people usually get money back
exactly six price tax is
basically the reasons have found that
there are very many people
who pay more taxes than they should
because they just
don’t submit the voluntary tax return and
that's a big market, but B of
course it's also
doing something good for people and they make it
very easy for people, which
means what they do on
tiktok is also relatively easy, they
often simply explain your product with
you  Green screen partly with Creator
and partly even the G  The founders
themselves who explain their product very clearly
and it works in such a way that
people I want that I have won thousands of
customers
or have meanwhile also made
larger financing now, so there is
already a good running company,
so to speak, who ultimately take on the
tax return  for
some kind of payment or or commission
or something, but I think
that there are other companies and
other products that can fully
get involved, why do
n’t they do that yet, yes, that is now being done by
a great many companies
from companies that you might still be able to
also on a European level zalando is
already very actively built
on tiktok you Tag Müller Tag
Müller is often a guest here
very very active also internationally on
tiktok they just did a
big event with Creator at the
Milan Fashion Week
Hugo Boss is internationally
activated this cabin that is yes
one of the big ones right
now they had at the Milan at the Milan
Fashion Week there I was actually
too they had opened Naomi Campbell
and then there was
kabelame and bellaporch as two big
tiktok racers they streamed the whole thing live
on tiktok the
also supported this without advertising
activation and just won the
hundred thousand followers with
it and just the videos
from the tiktoks from kaviarmee had
I think 55 million Bella Port from
the event had a reach of 38 million
so they have already achieved quite a
lot of reach with it
and  these are so there I can really
speak of such big companies now
a Deutsche Telekom is
another example well they do it
well they do it with their own
social media team so there is always
the possibility you have this
content and and they  Creation itself
or then often just
with agencies spec  ialists agencies
creative agencies or you work
with CREATON the people agency so let's say
Germany a whole series of
agencies that whenever a
new platform is created yes at Amazon it
was the same before
with SEO and Google say two
three names of agencies that you
at least notice more
often that I would love to do that, but
then everyone who doesn’t name you is
mad at me, so
yes, I think in the market there are also the good ones
who already know, I think
quite good to market so special
I think I heard from
Berlin they do a lot themselves now they
are also active there themselves
so something seems to be in good hands with them
that is definitely
one of the special agencies that are now
there too  we are very fit,
but we actually also help the
creative
agencies, i.e. the classic creative agencies, really the tikto
To bring k closer, we have our own team for this
and
the social and creator agencies, so to speak
, there are also the
classic creative agencies and
increasingly tiktok is also planned as a whole
in the overall campaign and
it is therefore also important that in the
in  the whole
thing also fits into the overall
communication
strategy and creative strategy and in
this respect we actually work
with all agencies first
because it makes sense for brances
to outsource an agency
you don’t have to do that so the
believe that says that he says
somehow successful  Social media,
especially Instagram back then, somehow you have to do it
yourself,
so to speak, to give
it to an agency and especially now with tiktok, where it has to be too fast and let's say it has to
be authentic somewhere
or have to be more unusual
, the agency can often be crass
In general
, an agency can achieve that
I can already do it, so the question is fundamental and I think it
varies greatly from company to
company
what role does social media play in
my value chain, am
I able and would I like to
build a team there on a permanent basis
or do I have a more complex campaign plan anyway
which I can't
completely map internally, I think it
always makes sense to
build up people internally and build up know-how for
a platform like tiktok, I think so
,
but
depending on the complexity,
working with agencies
makes absolutely sense and is understandable like
you  I think it depends on the
complexity of the customers, on the
marketing goals and in how many markets
are you active and so on and how
central that might also be
for your own value creation what is
currently when you
want to spend money that is very much what you do  then well
, I always understand an
organic rangeht then  do you try
to laugh videos yourself somehow
stand out if you switch heat with it
what do you do then what products
are there so
listen to video clips or what exactly do you get
so I would say the primary
product is are infeed in feet videos
that means you would  you within
your
one of the videos that you see when you
swipe through the app then we have
premium products for it, for example top
for that is what you see for
some days when you open the app
you have direct advertising these are
then so premium formats
and  the infeed ads as the
main product, there is then
another gradation or first a
top-feed product where that is only
number 4 once, so to speak, in the
order and the in-feed ads
are then just timed according to the
usual criteria
procedure goes on  here as with Google
and Facebook and so too, yes exactly
and where that differs again
and I think that is
exciting  d and it's important depending on the objective
you have then
different integration you can say let's say
we share now want to
promote an app they actually
did it then they have now
built the good creatives with their agency custom Ludwigs, for example
for tiktok where they must have clarified
what share is like and they then have
an install button, for example, where you are
then linked directly to the app
store Google Play Store
or Apple Store
and then you can download the app
got 50%, for example
, that can be a goal,
another goal can be malogica,
for example, they wanted to
sell products that make beauty products, for
example, what we can
use, for example, also against the dark circles under the
eyes and as an example they have
it  Creator worked with
Collection ADS the add format is
basically the same you can but
you can  t then, for example,
integrate products that you
can scroll through and click on and which you can
then go to where in the shop and
where of course you have a very easy
conversion that is more of a web
conversion optimization if you
do what trade
like now, of course  for example a
good example maybe Aldi Süd
yes they worked with big creators
so the melodic worked
with Nano Creator for example
they have 10 20,000
followers so relatively
pointed they were above all they were a
good fit for the brand
but Aldi Süd is for example  he went to
the wellness and then
basically had the same AT format but
then worked together with big
creators, yes, elevator boys,
you already have that, that means they take
these creators and then use them, how do
you get some of the money
we get
through which we earn by
advertising these
creators we end up producing a promotional video
d exactly that, yes, and we
actively advise to do so often or actually
always advise to check the cooperation with
creators who just fit well with the
brand simply because they make the
translation work very
easy as far as tiktok is concerned and for
us it is very important on  At the end that the
advertising works, yes, and
if part of the total budget is then invested in the
Creator, but the advertising
works, in the end we are very,
very fond of that
on Instagram,
I don't think that Instagram or
now Google are
actively involved in any way with Youtuber and says dear
customer, we would like that, but we
'll also have some kind of creator
from the platform, but you
also actively suggest creators and
who are they  so listen again and again you
see again and again who are there still
somehow particularly in demand the
creators he often recommends
iehlt in June it is certainly a very
popular creator but I think and
that is the big thing that the big
difference also with tiktok the
reach of the creator is
not the primary criterion from my point of view
but what you actually have to pay attention
to as a brand is that you  you are
looking for a creator who already fits the brand very well in what he
normally does
yes let's take another example moan
nutrition yes they have
a the name just not one of my
relatively nifty
catering 20,000
followers who worked together to create
their dietary supplements
promote like that but in its
normal in its normal creators has it
has already done something for the
fitness community always has something
to do with food yes that means it becomes totally
natural and totally authentic when
the product now
has an effect on the product features  not
fake, that means they
actually have to be in their briefing
don't write in a lot of dones
, they just have to roughly
give a bit of a direction, but they
can
give you a lot of freedom. An example of a
company that has grown extremely blatantly in the last year,
exactly, and
also with tiktok, among other things  is generally so that
now supplements may
benefit particularly well from tiktok
or fashion because in the end I always ask
there is a new platform who
benefits from it so or what
new companies can you build or build on
because Google
had them  whole SEO businesses
price comparisons that would not have existed without Google
at or dealers
certainly new kind somehow a
Zalando very strong yes we also
grew up with Google or grew up with SEO back
then in the early
phase when it was cheaper on Instagram
there was the same  many brights at Amazon
there are again individual brands what
kind of brands are created at eu
I have a good question, so I have a
little bit of it, we have already
discussed it,
the mallogica, that is, beauty products,
everything that I think you can
explain well, which of course goes well with the
target group, which you
might need a little bit of
explanation for  which is visual
but we actually now see
that we work for all industries that works in
all industries
yes bMW has already done a great deal for
us Porsche had over a million
followers on tiktok that means
we can also see that it is Mercedes  very
very active that means
I don't think Audi has to introduce it yet
exactly but we see
that I would even have a mobile automobile
brand Lamborghini is active yes that
means there is
really I don't see any
industry at the moment that isn't for the tik tok
is relevant even if we now take it in
the B2B area for the
employer branding is a rie  sen topic is
a huge topic on tiktok and that's why
I wouldn't limit it so much,
which is certainly correct
that the area that
adapted tiktok the fastest or first is
certainly the consumer goods area
, we've already seen that, we
also did a meta-study about it  the
Roas there
if you also
return to S-Band countries Excuse me
5.5 times as high as the media
average in Germany, so that
means extremely efficient also in
terms of sales
and that is certainly the
products are the easiest
However, in the meantime we have really
found recipes and strategies that
work for all verticals and
that is why we also have specific
teams, we have individual teams for each
vertical, which then specifically
point out which trends are relevant,
how can the address be made and also
a creative one  Implementation and the
solution looks just a little bit
looks different now for automotive than now for a Loreal, for
example, what role does music play, I
mean, in the end it is also very, very
strongly music and sound-driven
gymshark, the founder
was also a guest here in the podcast, also a brand
that you are actively involved in  uses there is even
some kind of stress with some music labels
are so
basically music plays a huge role yes that
means the music publishers also use us of
course to specifically
promote new artists and also to see
how can I now, so to speak, before a
release, for example  sometimes
increase demand for the respective
tracks and we saw a
lot of random hits I'll start with
the random hits the streams are back
in the charts so far Nina Schuber
is popular on tiktok but and
what exactly that is the topic music is
playing  a huge role it's always
soundcon and also in advertising and
in the creation of Spiel Mus  ik of course
and sound fundamentally a huge role
so it's always sound on
as far as the rights are concerned
I'm sorry to hear that what
we do from the poetry
side is of course to
ensure that we give
the right advice from our side that's right
if you
do advertising if you so i can
explain briefly sorry we
have to talk about distinguishing
between music that promotes itself, so to speak,
an artist or
label exactly and then of course music
that is used in other
products that's the way it is like me  straight
ahead that's exactly the difference that
means if you are now on tiktok as a private user
without commercial interest
then there is a very large
library of music and sounds that you
can use so that's all legally
clarified that's all that fits and
then we have another
commercial library, that is, if you
go there as a company  and if you say we
want to open a company
account, i.e. a business account then
and you create a tiktok with this business
account then you only have
access to the commercial library that
’s 2000 songs or so yes
and we’ve cleared the rights for them that’s it
all that is all clean so
if you place ads there is
an extra query
I have the rights I have the rights
for the music I use here yes
and of
course we also explicitly
point out that as in every advertisement in
every advertising  If you use music as a
company, whether this is with us
or on television or on other
platforms, if you use music, you
as an advertiser must of course
ensure that you have these rights
and we can do whatever we can
that we can integrate it into our
product logic  build in that we have
travel and, so to speak, failsafe on it and of
course we can
also explicitly transfer our  en
counseling talks, but
ultimately the
decision is then made by the brand,
but don’t you also pay royalties, so to speak,
to the respective music publishers
and something like that from the music that
you use for private
for private use not for them
commercial use understood or
for commercial use for this
commercial library, which we
also offer free of charge, but since it is
much smaller than the one that is
now available to all users,
okay, but I think that's
really something for the
music industry by now  Huge stream of proceeds,
both with you and with Instagram
and so to speak, music that is used on the
platforms has to be
paid for and money suddenly flows
back  there is dynamic
don't you sometimes think ah I should
actually  also set up an agency
for it yourself or set up a brand
for it yourself because you stand by
and observe everything that
somehow also tries to explain to people
then you are not on the wrong side
so I’m just
having too much fun at the moment I have to be
honest  with the team that I have there and
but I would say someone really asks
if someone asks me who
wants to found something with which area
then I would certainly say there
is one in the whole ecosystem
around tik tok whether that is now a  is your own
company that does something direct to the
consumer or is it
perhaps an agency that
helps to implement creative
I think there is a very exciting
area and there is also a lot of green
nature master
I definitely so we'll see if
we meet now  I'll say the ones who use it
when we
look at the use and, above
all, the feedback from the  Customers are
will we are we now we
certainly want to explain tiktok in the first year
the second year but shaped by
that certain that we give the companies
security tiktok is a secure platform
we have now achieved that yes
because to ensure user safety
because we work with third-party
providers  like iOS Sever, they will offer their own
brand filters, safety filters
and now
all customers are actually asking, okay, how do
I do that successfully on tiktok, how
am I successful on tiktok, how
do I implement it creatively and in the right way and in that respect
I think there is a whole  Lots of
needs, where do you think the customers get
the budgets from, those are deducted from the ones
you spend,
so those are then budgets that come from
television or from
Instagram or from Facebook or something like Google
or where
that’s a good question, I think that
sounds very different from customer and agency
, we leave that to them  so we at
concentrate on where we
feel strong because you yes, I think
yes, I think there will continue to be
a shift or if there will certainly continue to be
a movement from offline to
online
and
I think that can fundamentally
everyone comes from all budget pots, so
we also see that it can come from a
wide variety of budget pots
and, as I said, sometimes it
is de facto incremental,
especially when we talk about the topic of
performance as a totally singing lower
fundel, well then it’s
not necessarily  from the fixed
budget top but then a
company like Express Steuer simply grows
and talks invests a part, so to speak,
in new users and then with
us, another platform has
also grown and that can
also be simply
incremental from  all the
platforms this bit trying
to be like you now so man
It's definitely experienced that the
discussion is on Instagram because on
Youtube there are these shots with the
old employer at the end who does it
best
so I find the comparisons
always a bit difficult but
I would I would ask the same
question I thought  And that's
not just since I've been at tiktok,
but I think it's
always a very good
strategy to concentrate on what you're
strong in and
to take that as an incentive, so to speak, to continue being an
innovation driver when we look at
the topic of mobile  Watching short videos
, we are the largest platform, we are
certainly the platform that made the topic
big and we, what our
claim is,
want to be innovation drivers
and keep developing it, whether it is
now going live, for example, what
a huge, huge topic  is on tiktok
or just spoken B2B again in the direction of
Kommers solutions where we have a gr  We put a lot of
focus on it but that's ours
that's our focus life means live in the
room
it means increasingly creators just um
live also doing live streaming of
different events or
courses
and if there are courses explanatory videos etc and
sometimes there are also DJs  who play live
sets and what is very exciting we
now have live concerts together
with Deutsche Telekom we have brought big
concerts to tiktok, for
example Billie Eilish yes those are big
live formats and we also see
that Deutsche
Telekom is increasingly branding that now as  Sponsor but we also see
that brands use it themselves Hugo
Boss I said before
they streamed their Fashion Week
live from Milan
on tiktok okay I think that totaled
more than 100,000 and the evaluation was over 100,000 so
it was very significant  ok
do you think it's like that every
generation has it's own social
network so  we had already
discussed the podcast here from time to time I think a thesis from PIP so
every generation has their shop about you
and that will be a bit older country and
then their bank the n26 or something then
grows out of it and then something new comes up
or for  the younger
ones are coming something new is that so tiktok they will be
this generation now because they are not
between 17 18 today to 28 and then
[music]
that's the way it is and then it won't
get any older either and something new
will follow I believe that  it's very difficult
to make a prediction there
so i'm not very i'm not
very religious so i don't know
what i believe in but don't believe in that
but i would put it like that what i
see is what we see on tiktok it's
actually very
cross generational now  is
and also works, that
means we also see that in markets where the
target groups are even older but if
we already said ne are now also in
the 25 + 35 plus range  s where we
are growing strongly we are still very strong
in the young target group we see that
we have content creation from
several generations across several
i think what distinguishes tiktok is
it is primarily an entertainment
platform that is the primary
entertainment platform and we have  yes,
at the beginning we talked about how tiktok
actually works, that means you
have your individual your
individual yes for you in an
individual for you page your
individual stream and it looks
completely different when you are 18 now
than when you are 35 as a rule
maybe  there are also some who have the
same interests, but it
looks similar for every person
and if you have
different interests, you do
n't necessarily meet each other differently than
you do on a social network and I
think that's why a platform
like tiktok can
cross generations very well  also for the
next gen  Generation working
is always encountered in real somewhere
so this new one I heard about it
but not a topic for you I
haven’t dealt with it in detail if I
’m honest not yet what should I
actually do with tiktok so or
about he we’re already a
We have a colleague who is somewhat present
and who somehow plays a strong role here, because that
also happened during the target group,
but let's be specific I do
a little bit on LinkedIn on Instagram a
little bit on Twitter also do a
little bit
on tiktok I don't
hear it yet  I've been there, Gary
Vania Chuck has been there for a long time
and I think
Frank Thelen is from Germany too and he does a lot of
things
who does it well, what do you
recommend to me or to other people who
are listening here now and maybe
not now  are more than 25 and
somehow it came up what do you do there yes it
's a it's a very good question i
think green  In addition, there are
basically
a few best practices that you
should take to heart, uh,
tiktok is definitely a short mobile platform
, so of course
you have to make sure that you get
a hook very quickly,
so to speak  If you are now
looking at a classic storytelling then
I would certainly start with a
highlight or with a plan hook that
also keeps people in line,
so to speak, very very strongly
I think it is absolutely critical and that
may sound like a swap, but it is
It's not
to be authentic, that means being
yourself because that's what
you endure in the long term, so to speak,
and people notice that being
creative, but that doesn't
mean that you have to pretend, that does
n't mean that you somehow  must be a certain
kind of creation, which means you
can also use education content, for
example  I learned a lot with tiktok I
would have to check how many views there
are in Germany now they
are probably 7 8
billion news that means it can be
very democratic content it can be
inspiring
you can
actually go in all sorts of directions
but I think  the decisive factor is that it
naturally already has a
certain entertaining character
that people also bring in quickly, so to speak,
so what do you want to say, how
long can something like this be at most, I would
, of course, meanwhile we also offer
longer formats,
but the 530 usually work
Seconds plus minus is best,
so I would rather
stick to short, crisp formats and if
you then have a
certain following or
then just found the
right tone, you then have a
longer topic that works even then
a minute or two minutes at some point
a topic  One to
I would like to explain more but I would first start with short
content okay okay so
if you want to get involved with you in some way now
there is self-booking
you can probably try it out like that
but you can also call you if you
want to try out larger budgets with you
absolutely so we have one
Website where you can definitely reach
us that is called tiktok in front of
Business europe.com Saxony stays
slow again so Tick talk for business
europe.com Europe like Europe and um
but you can also
write to me via LinkedIn and I’ll put it
to the  corresponding budget you can
talk directly about which budget
service
so I would make it more dependent on
it, so to speak, what is the
way what is the kind of support that
the company needs and
accordingly we decide then
we then see how we support it
best but  we now have for
both small businesses
with smaller budg  There is a separate
smb team that has the right support
models and for large companies it
would be more complex,
we also have the appropriate teams
with article expertise and so on,
so I think we have
the right thing for everyone  now in
all these years tiktok so many
are not yet but what about
this high growd your
favorite anecdote suddenly you are
also the boss of 100 people
you are suddenly visible than as a
person on google it was
different again  no, there were other people in
charge who were certainly even more visible
to
you now you have to deal with everything when
people do what your favorite year
my favorite anecdote well
that likes now
that's actually so
we don't pander to it now
please come over it but it's real  so
that the omaf festival this
year was such a defining moment for us
because that was the first big
event  ent where we
that was even before we got the
whole team together for the
first time so I was like that at the
beginning before I ever got my
whole team together
that's later but later in the summer
due to the pandemic and then there were
a lot of people  of us there were
creators there were customers there were there
were brands and our stand was
literally bursting at the seams yes
and seeing that makes
it really real for me for the first time
because I did the mostly I
mean I started  or I
signed before the pandemic and
then I started and got a
laptop home like that and from
there I finally built everything up from a whole white sheet of
paper
like that
and that's sometimes a
little bit real for that's enough  so how
many people have you even heard several
hundred yes yourself not personally
but then of course I have something ic  h took it
with me is value
loved have very very strong
executives also to gentlemen who of
course
hired it and then they continued to hire me I did
more interviews in the first
year at tiktok than in 12 years at
Google, that is to say  that was already
more than 10
20 but I stopped
and then to see it for the first
time and because you take it you have
video conferences and stuff and then it's
somehow not really all that real
but then to see it for the first time when
then when it all comes together like
this it's been that for me
so I damn for days
insanely insanely electro
electrifies that will now of
course
give you a final word you don't even know
insofar yes thank you again for this in
any case not agreed I
just wanted to know because of course it's probably
still an
unusual situation
in your professional life  solut will
be maybe for decades
this phase is now cool in his company
thank you very much and
hopefully we will see you
again at the festival in May at the latest yes until
then everything is fine ciao ciao